[Music]
in if it ain't broke news fix it anyway
submitted by Shana thin video huh Shana
'then where is it from I don't know
sorry okay I got a new version of the
alphabet song has ticked off Twitter
have you heard this it's so dumb it's
also the version that James Cage white
sings on his new app is really ass dude
I type it and using the new version you
know what my favorite version is let me
play it for everyone
BB c d e f g let's go I never heard of
that it's funky like Sesame Street
what's a funky dude you don't know what
funky is what fair warning that's corny
that's funky who [ __ ] is that Louie the
Blowfish
why that's a classic funks always just
name is some white bands I don't know oh
but putting the bull face with a black
singer yeah yeah but it's still white
yeah yeah yeah those folders are no [ __ ]
see this [ __ ] he didn't even know that
guy stop fighting please
but what zip don't use words I don't
know this is the version that Twitter is
upset about have you heard this
yeah it's crazy who's it ready yeah
[Music]
thank you it is arrived anymore X Y Z
longer do it is I'm expecting it to end
with Julian Epstein didn't kill himself
[Laughter]
that's where you first learn flow from
stupid kids stupid kid you try make it
stupid they're like it's too fast
we can't order rhythm Lee challenge I
don't think knowing the song makes them
smarter the copyright they're like we
still want to get money honors sesame
sure want it's dull
there is no taki copyright because
Twinkle Twinkle and ABC those tamales
are exactly the same and they're old
enough to be uncopyrighted so this song
was created by his YouTube channel
called dream you wxy it's originally
recorded to teach children learning
English as a second or foreign language
so they can they found it much easier
for children to recognize and memorize
all of the letters this way and it has
since caught on around the most a
five-person LMNOP though this one was
first posted back in 2009 really yeah
but this it just recently went viral
because Noah Garfinkel that's a fake
name
no he is a TV writer for a B's and new
girl
he ended up tweeting this out with the
caption saying they've changed the ABC
song to clarify the LMNOP part and and
it is life ruined oh is it because
people thought LMNOP is one word like
one letter LMNOP like I got a why it'd
be confusing for someone who doesn't
speak the language
and it's also black sheep have you any
wool I was doing sorry for getting that
in your heads are us today we you should
sue us look up the Sesame Street
the funky one funky though don't say
that smile that doesn't slap funky as
Tim would say you were saying that so
much on set that I it's in my head at
all times you're like it really slaps I
never said slabs recent slaps OH
oh it does smile oh you're using it
wrong of course I am
music music slap sighs funky because the
bass lap slaps star lap in the bass
slapping a baby's new lingo things that
I just cannot get with it
I like your beating beating cheeks I
always like that one beating them cheeks
beating them cheeks yes what does that
mean it's like vinegar gets like
opinions beating the butt up it's like
drumming tell you having sex that's it
because there's cheeks and then you beat
in the cheeks yeah yeah yeah yes you
rubbing that [ __ ] bongo drums why
Bongo
I can't load this just sing it let's go
h i j k l
man LP you know I need to hear the beat
cuz it's not it's not flapping funky
right now it's sounding more like Grover
right I clicked on Internet course okay
it looks like a disco party with the
disco ball this one this oh yeah this is
the one oh yeah oh this kind of flap
spunky dog does it wait wait for it this
disco snap Bob yep my still funky though
I love how it drop and you're like mom
maybe there's a breakdown you guys are
delusional I think y'all are like
something Madonna affected you miss Ella
[Music]
still trying to make it slap funky well
that slapped funky it started funky it
got whele starts like that though no no
no that's the same I'm so sad are you
consuming a lot of kid content now cuz
it's a lot of changes to like [ __ ] that
we saw you know how like they're doing
reboots yeah dude it's so cool now
because the the programming now teaches
parents how to even talk to kids or like
how do you like it it's so next level
now like there's this one eggplant emoji
means deep pig no it's like you know
when kids go mommy mommy mommy mommy uh
and then uh yeah you're like talking to
someone and they want your attention
right away this one teaches a kid to go
hey we're gonna have a signal okay oh oh
I'll squeeze your hand to let you know
that I heard you and what and then and
then that's how you know that we're
gonna talk about that later so there's
like it teaches them like so many cool
things your family that's really cool
which channels do you watch Disney
Channel I actually I loved watching
Sesame Street as a grown-ass man because
it's actually super funny like they doin
a lot of jokes in there even the current
check the current [ __ ] yeah like I
remember just a few years ago watching
Sesame Street and cracking up were you
high no I don't get high oh and I loved
it yeah yeah yeah I cracked up shows
well throwing jokes for the grown-ups
that go over the kids heads but I still
crack up the the adults they get crazy
collapse too I Bruno Mars Jason Derulo
like just what's the joke that goes over
the kids heads like big birds like suck
my balls Grover and the kids are saying
they're waiting for their Joe the kids
like with balls and then like we're over
here cracking up it's lit Grover likes
to hug a lot is he still a hugger oh I
didn't really grow up watching Sesame
Street why I what did you watch weirdo
stuff Mister Rogers is watch not Gullah
Gullah island
Nickelodeon stuff like out-of-the-box
Goliath was weird as [ __ ] it was I think
it was Nick jr. [ __ ] what about
Gilligan's Island late-night TV - like
mash oh wow yeah Three's Company I Love
Lucy Lucy was my your raisin you're
raising a good one for that reason you
know it's a [ __ ] one Bob Newhart show
what the [ __ ] was that always tuned off
I tuned off Bob Newhart and [ __ ] Andy
Griffith yes whenever I was on right
afterwards I challenged its races for
some reason Titan is like a way I think
so I was like it just felt like
oppression so I'm like I like it
happy days was cool happy news was tight
mr. Miyagi's on that [ __ ] oh he was at
the restaurant owner right and he got
funnier and funnier man that guy got fun
he's really funny so funny said Barry
yeah he's in the rest of development
Barry tons of [ __ ] how is Barry it was
pretty it was pretty good and watch the
whole team was pretty good oh yeah
what are you watching these days what am
i watching these we finished it for ya
Oh slab isn't it good this claps photos
don't slap only music slaps guys oh
sorry the market because the Bears got
motives okay motive oh I miss motive did
you guys okay he just learned how to use
it today oppa real dad just trying it
out like a new high school but it's an
old word that we did they were trying to
bring back
get back you bring it back though she's
not using moded again then we know we
[ __ ] jump-started that mother loved
motive like oh you feel molded right now
did you ever okay after someone got
motive would you give them a rip is that
only my school or okay so like after
like okay put the hair off of your neck
real quick so I'll be like oh you got
motive that's a rip and then you liked
it you can you do that to baguette it's
just your school nerd no it's like this
game let's ask if you see it we walk in
poor urban school thing because what
kind of urban it's still urban if it's
Mexican I think so yeah mainly Mexican I
know but not not my elementary school do
you mean urban because the mixed her
neck a she I'm not even gonna even
school cuz everyone probably think I'm
the substitute teacher who's there to
save them probably yeah like what it was
a Lifetime movies
[Music]
you
[Music]